[Applause]
welcome back y'all you know our next
guest from the incredibly popular series
Vanderpump Rules as well as from her
recent third place finish on Dancing
With the Stars she's got a new book out
now it's called single AF cocktails say
hello to Ariana
[Music]
madx so you you got hurt a little bit
right on it yeah oh yeah I mean it's
grueling the stuff that everybody we're
all putting our bodies through with dude
I call that fat camp from hell yeah that
show is hard cuz people think like oh
you're Dance I'm like that is hard yeah
everyone's in rehearsal like four or
five hours a day and I'm sure and I and
most of us are not you know these are
pros and even the pros are sometimes
getting hurt seeing the physical
therapist being iced all the time so
it's like if they're doing it imagine
the C are also dying it is really fun
though is it it doesn't sound fun but
it's but it's awesome to watch other
people do cuz I'm not
suffering but I do like that cuz I
didn't know this side of you but now
you're going to be in Chicago on
Broadway I had no idea that you had like
Broadway dreams oh my gosh I no idea I
was a kid and I went to school for
theater and I lived in New York for a
while trying to pursue it and I just it
wasn't getting anywhere so move to LA to
try to you know make a name for myself
with hopes of coming back one day and
doing it and full CLE 20 years later
it's like here we are full circle yeah
that's amazing are you so excited I'm so
excited I'm also terrified but that's
what rehearsals if you can survive
Dancing with the Stars I think you're
going to be it's just a grueling I've
had a couple people on here that have
done that and it's just such a they say
behind the scenes they're like man it is
it's hardcore oh yeah I'm I'm very
excited and at least like with the show
you're learning the routine for the show
you're not learning different routines
every day I think that'll be really nice
because that is one thing with Like
Dancing with the Stars is like every
five days you're doing something
completely different which is cool to
break the botony I like the creativity
in that but just it's you know it's a
little you're going to be so great at
the routine with Chicago by the time
they end it because you're you know
doing it repeatedly so so yeah let's
hope so yeah you're going to kill it
you're G to K it so what are your
thoughts on the new season of vand ofcom
what's what's happening you know I
haven't seen it um did they not show it
to y'all like before no we usually get
the episodes like a few days before they
air so I'm sure we'll see them you know
a few days before that day in January
when it starts airing I think our show
thrives when it's at its realist and so
this season was very real to film so I
think it'll be good yeah I imagine
difficult um but let's move on yeah um
so uh so this is your second cocktail
book that you're coming out with but
this is cool because these are your own
recipes right yeah this is all me this
time so that is a really empowering
feeling yeah do you do you love making
up drinks you love doing you you're good
at that it's um it's a creative medium
for me I bartended for so long trying to
just survive as someone who wanted to be
in entertainment and I know you I was a
cocktail waitress I tried making drinks
and I'm not good at it so but I'm really
good at talking to people so it's a good
waitress yeah there you go and the thing
is is like you were such an inspiration
to me because you are someone who's able
to channel your feelings and your
experiences through music yeah and that
is your creative out that's therapeutic
yes and so this was very therapeutic for
me these stories and these cocktails
absolutely alcohol does help when you're
going through something um I love it so
wait we have one of Ariana's recipes
ready to taste I love my show um yes cuz
I mean we're doing this obviously look
this is OA our El oh there are El oh my
God thank
you thank you so what this looks like a
Moscow Mule is that what the situation
this is a holiday inspired mule so this
is a little spicier than your normal
Moscow Mule I love spice yes and I think
that's what I love about any holiday
cocktail I love the spice I love the way
it smells I love the way it tastes I
love the SP
yeah I hope I never you know like people
say you get older you can't handle spice
I hope that never happens to me I love
spicy stff much just have all the Tums
necessary exactly need the SP just ready
with r that's amazing so in the book
though this is kind of cute you separate
it's like phases of relationships right
yes what are the phases again like
honeymoon honeymoon um then I go through
uh betrayal Devastation resilience and
Ad Astra meaning to the stars because I
feel like that's something that is such
a un
Universal experience it's not unique to
me but I think that so many people who
have gone through something come out the
other side better and stronger and I
just really wanted to be able to tell my
story with that and Hopey hopefully
connect with other people I think it's
perfect especially when people are going
through a hard time like if I had a
friend that was going through a hard
time what a great book to get them and
like you'll want to stick to this
chapter yeah betrayal like you know I
just think it's a great gift idea as
well for people going through
and I think too like that's the thing is
like some chapters were harder to write
than others yeah and what's surpris
imagine honeymoon wasn't fun that was
the hardest one yeah no I set out to
write a Christmas song uh during my uh
divorce and then and I was like why am I
writing and then it ended up being kind
of a breakup Christmas album but that's
okay yeah yeah nobody had one of those
so I provided I provided something but
it is but it is funny like when you
because I thought oh it would make me
feel good to kind of you know just focus
on the positive side of you know
something but but it is it is
interesting it's hard to do when your
your heart hurts and you're trying to
write how like tap into that in that
moment yeah it's it's crazy anyway so
you this is what I love so book tour um
when they bring this up to you I mean
it's you're doing cocktail do you have
like is it a cocktail party I feel like
it should be like cocktails should be
there it's definitely going to be
cocktail party Vibes because I want
everyone to have fun and let loose
because I feel like and celebrate the
book celebrate what's the book so we're
going to be laughing we're going to be
playing playing games we're going to be
doing a lot of like intimate Q&A type
stuff just so that we can all feel like
we're hanging out and having a good time
what a fun book tour yeah you should
come yeah fine if you provide this I'm
there um so anyway let's do a quick
commercial break everybody Ariana's book
is called single AF cocktails be sure to
check it out we'll be right
[Music]
back
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home